من جانبها تحدثت عن هجره الرقائق الدقيقه
واشباه الموصلات من الصين الى روسيا رغم
العقوبات الصحيفه قالت ان وقفه تدفق اشباه
الموصلات الى روسيا يمثل مشكله صعبه بشكل
خاص احد الاسباب الرئيسه هو ان الصين التي
رفضت الانضمام الى العقوبات الغربيه على
روسيا تقع في قلب تجاره الرقائق العالميه
فضلا عن كونها مصنعا مهما للرقائق منخفضه
الجوده والسعر واظهرت البيانات العامه
استمرار التدفق الى روسيا مباشره من الصين
ما انعش واردات روسيا من اشباه الموصلات
بقوه لتقترب من متوسطها الشهري قبل حرب
اوكرانيا اضافه للصين ارتفعت الصادرات
التركيه من اشباه الموصيلات المماثله الى
روسيا من 79 الف دولار عام 2021 الى ثلاثه
ملايين الف دولار العام الماضي لتصبح
تركيا التي رفضت دعم العقوبات الدوليه على
روسيا مصدرا رئيسا لهذه السلعه الى موسكو
[موسيقى]